il fut un temps à droite pas primaire ni
de congrès encore moins de débats le
candidat était naturel en 1958 le
général de gaulle s'impose comme le
héros le libérateur après lui georges
pompidou s'inscrit dans le prolongement
1974 premières tensions deux candidats
un au centre à droite valéry giscard
d'estaing et jacques chaban delmas mais
le candidat du sort entretien a montré
qu'il s'inscrit dans la continuité de
georges pompidou vge fait son annonce
avec le portrait du défunt président
derrière lui je suis
président en
1988 après deux victoires de la gauche
la droite cherche des solutions pour
trouver le candidat leur permettant de
battre le ps une idée l'instauration de
primaires entre la droite et le centre
de quoi faire rire ppda à l'époque et
voilà qui nous amène à à la politique
avec du côté de l'opposition l'ouverture
d'un débat depuis hier sur d'éventuelles
primaires dans la perspective de la
prochaine présidentielle
dans un peu moins de 7 ans donc on a le
temps de voir venir finalement cette
idée de primaires restera au placard
novembre 1994 jacques chirac coupe
l'herbe sous le pied à tous ses
concurrents de droite en annonçant sa
candidature pour l'élection
présidentielle de 1995
qu'à cela ne tienne edouard balladur se
présentent aussi cet inédit un choc pour
le rpr une élection deux candidats mais
c'est finalement jacques chirac qui
passera au second tour les français
l'ont décidé c'est monsieur jospin et
monsieur chirac qui seront présents
aussi
je vous demande de vous arrêter jacques
chirac sera élu président pour deux
mandats quid de la suite en 2007 les
militants ump réunis en congrès désigne
nicolas sarkozy en même temps c'était le
seul candidat un retour au candidat
naturel de la droite c'était en tout cas
l'ambition de la mise en scène de ce
sacre est en quelques secondes la droite
a tourné une page porte de versailles
sur le lieu du chiraquisme triomphant
nicolas sarkozy est intronisé candidat
de l'ump pour l'élysée 2016 après un
mandat du ps pour la première fois la
droite et le centre s'organisent pour
mettre en place des primaires ouvertes
c'est un succès plus de 4 millions de
participants et la victoire de françois
fillon la victoire me revient et c'est
une victoire de fonds bâti sur des
convictions mais françois fillon est
rattrapé par des soupçons d'emplois
fictifs le candidat ne passe pas le
premier tour pour la droite
cet échec restera un traumatisme et les
primaires ouvertes les responsables est
ce que la formule d'une désignation par
les militants en congrès sera la bonne
pour les républicains réponse en 2022
[Musique]